The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, a recap
of our last lecture--
there are many, many,
many terminologies
in the last lecture.
We basically start from
the Boltzmann equation
under relaxation
time approximation.
And we derived the expression
for the charge flux,
current flux, which
current density, and also
for the heat carried
by the charge.
And so we have the
coupled equation
for electrical transport.
I have to, like I
point out before, I use
the different symbol Je and JQ.
Je is for electron, JQ
in the book for heat.
And always the challenge is
to deal with the negative sign
of electron.
So I put a q, small q, just
for whatever is positive
is for whole, negative,
that's for electrons.
And then I used a capital Q.
So that's what I did
in the last lecture.
And so we have those
coupled equations.
And those type of
coupling is very common
when you deal with say
the transport processes.
Here we do the electron
and the heat coupling.
I said when you do piezoelectric
and heat and mass transfer,
there are all those
type of relations.
And if you generalize
the gradient
by the generalized entropy
gradient as the force,
then you have the Onsager
relation between those coupling
coefficients.
In the generalized form,
those coupling coefficients
are equal to each other.
But since we're not
writing into the entropy,
we're writing
temperature, so L 2y
equals T L1 2 in this
specific expression we use.
And from this, it's natural to
say when you have a temperature
gradient, you also have,
even in the open circuit
case, or any conductor
or semiconductor,
you have the Seebeck,
you have voltage
generated if you have
a temperature gradient.
And the Peltier
effect is when you
have a charge flow
in the conductor,
even if you don't
have a temperature
gradient, associated with
the charge flow is the heat
current, is the heat flow.
And that's the Peltier heat,
which has manifested itself
when you put two material
together and form a junction.
And because of discontinuity
in this Peltier coefficient,
you have cooling or
heating at the junction.
But fundamentally,
it's an effect that
happens in the same material.
So we talk about the
material properties,
Seebeck coefficient,
Peltier coefficient material
properties.
And similarly,
Thompson effect is
the Seebeck and
Peltier were actually
experimentally discovered.
But Thompson effect
is Lord Kelvin
predicted when he tried
to unify and then give us
a general interpretation
of what's a Seebeck
and what's Peltier effect.
He discovered there has
to be a third effect.
That's when you
have a temperature
gradient and the current flow at
the same time in the material,
then you have distributed
local cooling and the heating
along every point
in the material.
So the relation between
those coefficients
are Kelvin relations.
And you can see there
are a lot of relations.
That's because all those
expression, flux expression,
is derived at least under
the framework we're talking,
the relaxation
time approximation.
You don't have to use that.
But eventually
those coefficients
are all related back
into the relaxation time.
So we have say the relation
between electric conductivity
and thermal conductivity for
charge, Wiedemann-Franz law,
we have relationship between
Peltier and Seebeck effect,
that the Kelvin relation.
We also have in the
electrical engineering,
say the drift-diffusion
equation,
which is actually just
the first term of the JQ.
L1 1 is the electric
conductivity.
And then when you run into
the separate expression.
When we split out
the driving force
for the current flow, which
is electrochemical potential,
that includes the
chemical potential
and electrostatic potential.
The chemical potential is
related to the carrier density.
So that's a gradient.
That's a diffusion term.
And electrostatic
potential gives you
the force, electrical
force, acting on the charge.
So that drives the drift.
So drift is a measure
of the mobility.
Diffusion is a diffusivity.
And again, the relation between
diffusivity and mobility
is the Einstein relation.
And in fact, that
Einstein relationship--
I made a comment that
Einstein didn't do electron,
he did the Browning
motion for molecules.
And he has relation between
the mass diffusivity
and the viscosity.
And that's a special case.
All those are special case of
the fluctuation dissipation
theory.
So the fluctuation gives the
Browning motion diffusion.
And dissipation
is the viscosity.
Mobility, that's
the correlation.
So all things are tied together.
A lot of terminology, but the
are intrinsically connected.
And by the end of
the lecture, we
went to discuss the
thermoelectric device.
A real device is typically
made of pairs of P and N.
And then you connect
them electrically by--
typically it's a metal.
And then say this is the
basic construction unit.
And you repeat them many
times in a commercial device.
And the reason for this,
you connect the many of them
together, is because
the typical ZT,
similar as a electric
figure of merit.
When you get a ZT,
the largest case
in commercial material, which
is bismuth telluride base.
Right the Seebeck
is of the order
of 200 microwatt per Kelvin.
And the electric
conductivity is of the 10
to the 5th ohm per meter.
And the ohm per meter,
inverse ohm is also siemens.
So it is siemens per
meter, or siemens
per meter, different unit.
So it 10 to the 5th,
so the materials
are actually very conductive.
Metals, electric conductivity
is 10 to the 8th of the order.
Yeah, I think it's order--
two or three order magnitude
higher than this semiconductor.
Typically we use as a
common doping concentration
is around 10 to the 19th.
And if you make a silicon
device in microelectronics,
the doping concentration
is typically 10
to the 17th, so two order
of magnitude smaller.
So this is-- each leg
is about a millimeter
in commercial device.
And the resistance electrical
resistance is a milliohm.
So we have milliohm,
you've got a large current.
And so you put a
lot of legs together
to increase the electrical
resistance and that way you
your operation is easier.
You don't have to have that
large current operation.
And the thermal conductivity is
made of electronic contribution
and the phonon contribution.
And this is of the order
of 1 watt meter Kelvin.
And this value is
comparable to glass.
Glass is 1.2, and
this is a similar--
typical material is
actually about 1.5.
And so you want
the material with
the high electric conductivity,
no thermal conductivity.
And you want the electron
carry a lot of heat.
Seebeck is the entropy, average
entropy carried per charge
I mentioned.
So that's the dilemma there.
You have to play
with the material.
So you try to--
it turns out that you change
one, you also most of the time
are changing the others.
And there is a nice terminology
to describe what you really
want.
You want-- this is a
so-called phonon glass.
So for lattice
vibration, you want it
like a glass,
which is amorphous.
And amorphous material
typically do not
conduct electricity well.
So you want the
electron crystal.
So phonon glass,
electron crystal, but you
want this happening
in the same material.
So this is where
the challenge is.
And they're trying to fool
the material for the lattice
vibration, you say this is like
a very poor heat conductor.
And for electron, is like
a good electric conductor.
And typically,
bismuth telluride,
why it's good it's
because it's heavy.
And when it's heavy, the
phonon frequency is low.
The group velocity is small.
And intrinsically, the
thermal conductivity
is going to be lower.
And the other way to use it
to reduce thermal conductivity
is by alloy.
The mass scatter, for example,
silicon, thermal conductivity
150, germanium is about 90.
And then when you mix
the atoms together,
the difference of
the mass now, if you
think about having a chain,
of each atom is the same,
you got a harmonic
vibration, very harmonic.
But each mass point, you
put a different mass,
you know that string is not
going to vibrate very well.
And that's a mass difference
scattering, alloys scattering.
And that's the
typical way to reduce
the thermal conductivity.
And of course, you want
to do it not to reduce
the electrical conductivity.
So we discussed some of
the typical characteristic
of s sigma k.
And if you engineer-- or say
most of you are engineers--
so what's important
is to match--
it turns out the
device you can size
the different
cross-section area, height.
And you actually have
to match the two sides,
because the analysis
I gave is just 1 leg.
When you put the
two leg together,
you'll see area, length ratio
has to be matched together,
maximum performance.
So there are a lot
of optimization
at both materials level and
also at the device level.
OK, any questions?
So if you look at the
energy research, and right
now there are a lot of--
of course of great interest,
and a lot of energy devices.
There are not many stuff, right?
A lot of people
work on solar cells.
work on batteries.
And the rest is--
you just say people all want
to work on say energy related,
so you suddenly
see a lot of people
now work on thermoelectrics.
Right but actually
thermoelectrics
are fun in the sense you really
have to fool the material.
And it goes into a
non-linear regime.
Everything is scattering.
You want to control
transport, you
have to control the scatter.
So it's both difficult, and
if you like it, it's fun.
OK, don't like it,
it's a headache.
When I got into thermoelectrics,
the first thermoelectric
program--
so if you look at
history, in 1821
Seebeck discovered the effect.
Around 1900, this parameter
ZT was formulated.
So how you make a
generator, you need
a material with the high ZT.
And around 1950, bismuth
telluride was discovered.
And that's when so
this was by Goldsmid.
And when he discovered
bismuth telluride,
he said that he was just
actually very lucky.
He said the first
guess he found it.
Here's a good physical insight,
said you need a heavy material.
Heavy material turns out
are also usually have
better mobility,
charge mobility.
And so he tried bismuth
telluride and it worked.
And so most commercial device
was based on bismuth telluride.
And then say for
power generation NASA
was interested because
the solid state.
And it's based
on-- but they have
to go to a higher temperature.
Bismuth telluride is not stable.
So they went to a silicon.
Silicon germanium is
by the idea of alloy,
that's the Russian scientist
Ioffe proposed alloy can
reduce thermal conductivity.
So that led to develop
a silicon germanium.
And silicon germanium has
been used the most NASA flight
for deep space missions.
And they use a nuclear waste--
not nuclear waste-- nuclear
fuel to generate the temperature
difference, generate heat.
And that has turned out that
for space it is very reliable.
And those generator work,
not very efficient, 5% to 6%.
But they've been sending back
signals, some of those space
missions, over 30 years.
And for cooling, has been
based on bismuth telluride,
terrestrial applications
based on bismuth telluride.
So commercial modules
all use the pretty much
the mature developed
in the '50s and '60s.
So there are not much
research in this.
And in '90-- around in the
'90s, so there are people--
sometimes you also have to give
credit to the program manager.
And they started asking
whether there is anything
new in thermoelectrics.
And one of the person they
ask was Millie Dresselhaus.
And so many Millie
told me all the story.
And she said, it was not
actually the military,
it was a friend that
I keep talking--
somebody who ran in bus in
a conference and get her,
told her about thermoelectrics.
And then when the
military came in,
ask her whether she
had an idea, there
happened to be a graduate
student looking for a research
topic.
And so he asked him to
calculate the quantum well.
So the idea of a quantum well.
We want the S squared
sigma electron better.
If we look at the density of
states of bulk material, that's
a square root E relation, it's
parabolic, density of states.
And this is energy.
And remember here is Ec.
It depends on where
you put the Ef.
I said the Ef, if you put it
here, this if this is the Ef,
you dope it.
And then we say the Seebeck is
measure of the average energy
from the Ef.
So electrons-- there's
no electrons below Ec,
this is big gap, semiconductors.
So most electrons
in this region,
because of the Fermi Dirac.
The Fermi Dirac
has Ef is the 0.5
distribution, and the
exponential decay very rapidly.
So there are not many--
so if you plot the energy level,
what's the occupancy, is this
is the Fermi Dirac distribution.
And this times this means this
is Ec only a small portion.
These are the portion that
contribute to charge transfer.
You look at the expression
for electrical conductivity.
You had this homework of
looking at a different product.
So only electron
near Ec bottom here
contribute to the transport.
The rest is too high energy.
They are not a field.
They are empty states there.
OK, so here is Ec.
And the problem was this is
here a typical parabolic event.
There are not many carriers
here if you look at it.
This is the lowest density
of states region, not
many energy carriers.
So you did a density of
states of quantum well.
The quantum well is staircase.
So now rather than
this parabolic,
you have a staircase.
And of course you dope it again.
And suddenly you've got
a lot of carrier here.
And so carrier,
number of carriers
proportional to
electric conductivity.
So by making this a
sharp fissure and then
you control your doping, you can
get-- theoretically-- you can
get a larger s squared sigma.
So this was the
first paper published
by Hicks and Dresselhaus on this
using quantum ideas to increase
the s squared sigma.
And Millie is a
expert on bismuth.
So she's an expert on
carbon and bismuth.
Carbon, she wrote
an important paper.
That's before carbon
nanotube was discovered.
She been always talking
about the carbon.
And she wrapped
that up and say what
if the energy level
if you have a tube?
So thus they escaped,
the Nobel Prize
escaped the carbon nanotube.
She missed that.
It went from the C60,
there Richard Smalley
discovered carbon-60.
And then last year, it
went to the graphene.
Right so the tube was missed.
Anyway, so always do very
conceptual, very simple,
but it made a big impact.
And this is the idea,
doing the quantum well.
And the other idea she had was
say bismuth is a semimetal.
OK, there's no gap.
So you have an equal
number of electron holes.
And the Seebeck
coefficient is low
because they cancel each other.
And so she say OK, if
you use this quantum size
effect, that's your quiz
exam, electron move up,
host move down, so you
turned that semimetal
into a semiconductor.
So by using size, theoretically,
all this possibility
and they increase-- really
drove a lot of interest
in this problem.
So that was around '93.
And at that year, I didn't know
anything about thermoelectrics.
I was working on
semiconductor lasers.
And I was worried that
heat cannot get out.
So this lasers has a
lot of layer structure.
And that's the quarter-- if you
recall the Bragg reflectors.
The Bragg reflector, the
quarter wavelengths layers--
and I know that
they mean free path,
I saw this has low
thermal conductivity.
First the thinking
was a stop bands may
reduce thermal conductivity.
But see also the
classical size effect,
the mean free path
could be larger
than the thickness and
that can have a lower
thermal conductivity.
So that's what I
was interested in.
But I didn't know anything
about thermoelectrics
until a program came out
in '96 and learned this.
Somebody say, oh, you
should look at it.
So I look at it and say
that's what they need.
I say I can work
on the denominator
here, and team up with many
to work on the numerator.
So it took me five
years to at least
to get to really know
what is thermoelectrics.
By we had finally learning this.
So there are a lot of current
research in thermoelectrics
and many, many different ideas.
The challenge is putting
into real material.
There are always things that
you didn't quite realize.
And most ideas don't work.
But you have to keep thinking.
There are a lot of
progress made in the field.
OK that's the comment
on thermoelectrics.
And now let's coming back
continue to few more things
in this chapter.
The question is, so in
all the previous course,
you've probably heard about
the local equilibrium, right?
When you do heat
transfer, say we
talk about local equilibrium.
What does a local
equilibrium mean?
So what is the
local equilibrium?
And we know if the
object is at equilibrium,
the energy states
obeys Fermi Dirac
and Bose-Einstein distribution.
And those distribution
is isotropic.
So this is F0.
When we saw F0 is isotropic.
That's an equilibrium.
In each that there is no
net flux because there
are equal amount of heat
or charging any direction
versus the opposite direction.
So you don't have a left flux.
That's equilibrium.
And if you look at the
simplest form of a solution
is tau Vx df 0 dx.
This is the simplest form we
used to derive the Fourier law,
for example.
And you plot-- this is how we
derive for Fourier law, right?
So what really is giving
the flux is the deviation,
this term is given the flux.
F0 does not give you the flux.
So if I plot f itself in the
forward direction, if this
is my flux direction, in the
backward direction is this.
So what I have, the
difference between the two
is this section.
That's the going forward,
the left forward,
and there's less going backward.
It's this two contributing
to the real flux.
So what local equilibrium
means is this deviation
is small from the equilibrium.
That's our assumption,
right, when
we do the perturbation
f equals f0 plus G,
this is the G, small
compared to f0.
It's under that approximation
we can derive the Fourier law,
we can derive the shear
stress law and Ohm's law.
So local equilibrium still
means there's no equilibrium.
Here, what I have
is no equilibrium.
It's just a deviation from
the equilibrium is small.
and So then we can ask,
what are the conditions when
these are no longer valid?
So if I go back to the Boltzmann
equation under relaxation time
is a way.
And let's say delta
rf, I can say just
consider the case of
phonon, and the electron
has a momentum term.
So what I want is f minus f0 to
be small compared to f itself.
So I can think
about the condition
I have, then, is here.
Let's say tau Vx df0 dx must
be much smaller than f0.
that's my condition
for the perturbation.
And then now if I do
the order of magnitude,
tau Vx is the mean free path.
OK, so this order of magnitude
is the mean free path.
And the f0, df0 dx I
can say f over the L,
this is the order
of magnitude I have.
I'm not doing anything exact.
I'm doing approximate
derivative by f0
over L. L is your transport or
whatever gradient direction.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: I'll tell you.
There's something wrong
with the equation.
GANG CHEN: This is
not an equation.
This is a hand waving.
AUDIENCE: The df dt--
tau df dt to the left, left--
GANG CHEN: Here?
AUDIENCE: Left.
GANG CHEN: Left--
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, here I-- yeah.
OK, so what I have
here is a hand waving.
When you do order of
magnitude analysis,
you write a gradient by
say find difference term,
and give you this order.
And so what it tells me one
condition is the mean free path
is much smaller than
characteristic length.
When the mean free
path is comparable
to the characteristic
length of transport,
the assumption is not valid.
Right so that's one condition.
And this is where most of the
time when we do micro nano,
we're concerned where we fall
into this size effect regime,
when the mean free
path becomes longer
than characteristic length.
In fact, you can do another--
let's write mean
free path df0 dx,
I write the df0 dt and
dt dx less than the f0.
OK, and again, I do
this over T, this order
of magnitude speaking--
f0 cancel on this side.
dt dx is delta T over
L, much less than 1.
So what I'm saying here
is the gradient, dt dx,
should be much less than--
you can look at the
temperature or mean free path.
The reason I say this
is for this case,
it's a very easy if I do
a film, the mean free path
is longer than the
film thickness,
I will have a size effect.
And I'm concerned that the local
equilibrium assumption may not
be valid.
But there is another case
where my temperature gradient
is too deep.
If I have a transient transport
and the temperature gradient
varies a lot over
mean free path,
then this is also a concern.
Your Fourier law
may not be valid.
And the third case
is real transit,
if I look at the transit term,
this one approximately df0 dt,
and that also should
be much smaller.
So say the time
wise, you can look
at this is tau over T must
be much smaller than 1.
Relaxation time versus
the transport process,
much, much smaller than 1.
So these are the conditions
for this nuclear equilibrium
assumption to be valid.
And when the law is valid,
you say I need to be varied.
And one way to--
one equation that's very famous
called the Cattaneo equation,
it's trying to
address this issue.
And this is the rationale
the historical development
for this transient
problem is if you
look at the semi-infinite
object and you solve the heat
conduction in for
semi-infinite object,
it's a parabolic equation.
The temperature
decays exponentially.
But the exponential decay
means at the T equals 0.
You give the temperature
of the surface
a disturbance, infinite
away, there is fin in there.
Infinite small, but it's not 0.
So that means the heat
is propagating faster
than the speed of light.
So that's a dilemma in the
Fourier heat conduction
equation.
And on of those
approximation-- the reason
that one of the
equation to answer this
is to modify this heat
conduction equation as Q
equals minus k dt dx.
This is called the
Cattaneo equation.
But I say so there are
hundreds of people written
on this, because you have a
new equation there are always
people are good at
the math solving it.
But I say this most of
the time is not correct
because I say if you go to
look at the Boltzmann equation,
here, right, you go to here.
In fact, I say you'll find
that you can transform you
put a tau onto the other side--
oh, here should be
a tau, otherwise
the unit is not right.
So you put a tau on this side.
You integrate times of
velocity times the h omega
times the density of states.
So you integrate both sides.
You will actually
get this term, you
get this term, that's
this term here.
And it's this term, you
approximate it still
with the Fourier law.
So I say this is the most of
the time as academic exercise
because when you have very
fast temperature process,
your gradient,
the gradient term,
the spatial gradient
that typically exists,
and because of spatial gradient,
you cannot approximate this
term by the Fourier law
because we're doing--
we're replacing that
gradient f by f0.
So this is what I say.
There are many PhD
statements written on this.
And say I say that's a waste
of time, unfortunately.
And you have to really
understand what you're
doing when you deal with those.
So comment, that's
the one comment.
The next comment
I want to make--
I'm not going to
go into the detail.
It's all in the book.
Very interesting, you can read.
So what we have derived is
a constitutive relation.
The relation between
temperature gradient,
the heat flux, velocity
gradient, shear stress,
electrochemical potential
gradient current,
that's constitutive relation.
And you can actually start
with Boltzmann equation, derive
conservation equations.
And so if you recall when
you derive the Navier-Stokes
equation for fluid flow,
what do you use before,
or you derive heat
conduction equation,
you use the
constitutive relation
together with the energy and
momentum balance conservation
equations.
That's how you derive
those equations, right?
And you can start from
the Boltzmann equation
and you take the moment.
f is the distribution
function in phase space.
So if you multiply by the mass
per particle on both sides
and then you integrate,
you have to do
a summation of all the
states on both sides.
You will get mass
conservation equation.
And if you do--
so this is per
particle, because when
we do all the Navier-Stokes
equation or heat conduction
equation, we do not have any
variable in the momentum space.
It's a real space variable.
So when we sum up all
the momentum variable,
you're taking the
average on both sides
of the mass, total mass,
any location there.
And if you do your
momentum, you put
in the momentum per particle
into the Boltzmann equation,
and again your
average both sides,
you will get at
the left hand side,
you will have the convection
term in the Navier-Stokes
equation.
On the right hand side,
you'll get the right hand
side of Navier-Stokes
pressure and the newton shear
stress, the shear stress
term, viscose term.
But there you still have to put
in the constitutive relation
to get the Newton shear stress.
So you say here, you still
are using the approximation.
Navier-Stokes equation is
approximation because of you
approximate the Newton
shear stress term.
As same you can do energy.
So on this side, say the
fluids has more higher order,
you can do higher order moments
and there are modifications
to Navier-Stokes equations.
But what's interesting
is that you
go to look at the history
of electrical engineering.
And in the 1980s, the
electrical engineer
started doing sims
then and they derived
the electohydrodynamic equation
for electron transport.
So you go to check
the derivation,
I think in my book
their reference to this,
you check the derivation.
So in '98, in the
literature '98,
they did a lot of
paper trying to solve
electrohydrodynamic equation.
And the reason for that is
at the time the gate length
is becoming smaller.
And people were worried
the size effects.
So they went to
electrohydrodynamic equation.
And of course, if
you look back, if I
say that seems to be really not
the right approach because we
know the Navier-Stokes equation
is not valid when the mainframe
path is say longer than
they carriers can transport,
dimension, right?
So when you do
hydrodynamic, you're
not solving that problem.
You're still doing
the local equilibrium.
And of course the high
field, there is a convection.
So those things may
say how the electron
effect may be captured.
So I do not think
there are really
many people nowadays solving
electrohydrodynamic equations.
But even you go
to check, there is
electron shear stress, electron
temperature, very fuzzy,
the discussion there were
very fuzzy in the literature.
And then you go to
phonon, there are also
phonon hydrodynamic equation.
These were in
Russian literature.
And nobody has solved it.
I haven't solved any solution.
So you see there is--
the point that it's
all related, right?
And different fields that
has probably some field
developed tools.
And the other people learn and
apply to different problems.
But see, you got to
understand that what are
the basis when you apply it.
So that's all on
this chapter six,
which is really starting
from the particle transport.
Then we learned the
diffusion theory.
And what we're moving on is
looking into classic or size
effect, that's Chapter 7.
OK, so now we get into--
want to look at the regime when
those approximations are not
valid.
And we can start
with the problem
where I'm looking at
the heat conduction.
I do heat transfer now, heat and
conduction along a thin film,
freestanding thin film.
OK, and let's say
the mean free path--
we know the mean free path of
phonons and the mean free path
is longer than they
film thickness, d.
Now even though I
have-- let me first
consider the transport
along x direction.
So my q is flowing
along the film.
And even though the q is
flowing along the film,
we know the phonons
go all directions.
So phonons, the
momentum space, if it
goes this direction
and the mean free path
is longer than the
distance I draw here,
you will collide
with the boundary.
And of course once
collided with the boundary,
they will be
scattered, reflected.
And that depends on the
boundary condition, roughness,
for example, at the boundary.
We know when light hits the
surface like a table here,
it's a diffuse scatter.
If you put a mirror there,
it's a spectral reflected.
Reality may be
somewhere in between.
And this is, in fact,
still, nobody really
knows what's happened
at the boundary.
So the assumption
we'll be doing first
is a diffuse, so
is isotropically
scatter in all directions.
And in this case
conceptually, you
know you have worse
heat condition than when
you don't have the boundary,
because otherwise the heat will
go from here.
If you say this is a mean
free path in bulk material,
heat will go from here to here.
That means at least
the distance was in x
direction is this distance.
But now because of diffuse
scattering, the boundary,
half of them were going
back much earlier.
So those kind of
size effect typically
will impede your transport.
And let's go to say what
the equation tells us.
I'm going to solve this
equation, the Fourier law.
And I have an x direction.
And let's say the x direction
are very long, it's not finite.
But say y direction is finite.
So we have-- in this case,
I have Vx df dx plus,
let's say here is y
direction, Vy df dy.
And z direction, I don't have a
gradient, so I can drop that z.
I'm only considering
x direction flow.
So I have minus f minus
f0 steady state over tau.
This is the equation
you want to solve.
And I'm going to
again look at the--
at least to say I
have two direction,
df dx in the x direction.
So if I do g equals f minus f0,
now that's a small deviation.
But this is my difference there.
And I substitute this
into the equation
here, what I get is Vx
df0 dx, and then dg gx.
But the x direction, my
variation is relatively small.
I say the x direction
are very long.
So that deviation dg
dx can be dropped out.
So what I have is Vx df0
dx in the y direction.
So df0 dx, f0 then
is a function of x.
I have 1d transport.
So df0 dy also drops out.
So what I have is a Vy dg gy
and it equals minus g over tau.
So this is-- what
I really am looking
at is the variation because
of the boundary in the y
direction, I have
variation, size dependence
on the distribution.
So different point, I have
different f in the y direction.
And so what I'm going to look
at when I rewrite this equation,
Vy dg dy plus g
over tau and that
equals negative Vx df0 dT dT dx.
So you can say if I do not
keep the first term, that's
essentially what I had before.
I'm only keeping an extra term
due to the constraint in the y
direction.
OK, now you can solve this
first order differential
equation for g.
And if it's the first
order differentiable
equation, how many boundary
conditions you need?
Yeah?
Somebody can speak up.
You know It's only one, right?
You need the only one
boundary condition.
You need one boundary condition
for any pair of Vx Vy,
because Vx Vy are random,
phase based variable.
So basically what it's
saying is, you see here,
any direction you look
at, this is the direction
that they're propagating.
And you need a boundary
condition in this direction.
And any point, if it's
an internal point,
I have direction propagating
360 degree, all space,
and this one coming from here.
So I need a boundary condition
either on this surface
or on this surface.
And if you can specify one
surface for 360 degree,
it's a 4 pi solid
angle, you're fine only
starting with one surface.
But most of the time, because
I have two constraints,
and it's better to do for the
one that traveling from leaving
this surface, I have
boundary condition here
for this half on bottom.
So that together gives me 4
pi solid space, real space.
OK so now let's solve this.
And Vy-- so this is
at any point this is y
direction and the x direction.
At any point-- let's say this
is a Vy Vx that determine
the propagation direction.
And it's again your
choice of whether you
use a Cartesian coordinate or
use a spherical coordinate.
And then whether-- if you
use a spherical coordinate,
which direction you'd say
this is your polar angle,
which are another angle.
It's all your freedom.
And for this problem, I'm going
to do this one as my theta,
and then say xz plane is
as a [INAUDIBLE] plane.
So with that, I have--
again, so in this case,
assume V is isotropic.
In real crystal, they
are not isotropic.
So V is isotropic.
So I have V cosine theta,
that's the Vy and dg
dy plus g equals--
the right hand side is a
term that depends only on x
Vx, I have to be careful.
It's dependent on say theta
phi but doesn't depend on y.
So I solve this equation.
And the way I
solve it-- in fact,
because this is a function
of x, so you say g minus s0 x
equals--
it's a homogeneous equation.
You do a new
variable, g minus s0,
and then it's V cosine theta.
So I have a c exponential
minus y V cosine theta.
That's my solution.
And you plug in
this back into here.
You don't believe
it, you can check.
There should be 0.
So this is my solution.
And I said that we need
the boundary condition.
Either y equals 0--
if y equals 0, the boundary--
if the boundary is diffuse,
so it goes out isotropically.
That's corresponding to f0.
This f going out is equal to f0.
So g equals 0 at the y equals
0, because f equals f0.
So g equals 0, y equals
0, so I have c s0.
So what I have is g equals
for theta at the y equals 0.
Then this means theta
is a larger than say 0,
less than 90 degree.
I have g equals s0 and
exponential minus y V cosine
theta minus 1.
And cosine theta is also
called directional cosine.
Mu equals directional
cosine theta.
So that's just a symbol.
So I can write in
terms of mu rather than
take the whole cosine theta.
OK, so this is for y equals 0.
And similarly, you look
at the upper plane,
you say g equals again s0.
And the exponential,
if I look at this,
will be d minus y gamma--
oh, did I miss a tau?
I should have a tau somewhere.
I have a tau.
I should-- let me do this.
I put a tau on both sides.
So write an extra equation.
Tau y tau dg dy plus g equals
minus tau Vx df0 dT dT dx.
So I put a g--
so this is a tau.
I have tau.
So that should be at tau.
Tau times V is mean free path.
OK, so tau times V
is a mean free path.
And divide that
by mu and minus 1.
And this is a for theta is
less than 180 degree, larger
than 90 degree.
And this is the flowing
from the-- leaving
the first surface, the upper
surface into the media.
So what I have here, you can say
this is an exponential decay,
because of course, that mu
in 90 to 180 is negative.
So this is always--
it's from surface it
decays, surface it decays.
That's how I decide my sign.
Physical, you can think
about in physical terms.
OK, so I have the
solution for g.
That means I know my f,
because the f is f0 plus g.
So once I know f, I
can go to find out
what's the heat transfer.
So I can find out words,
the heat transfer.
My heat transfer through
any plane of x is--
this gives me any point
along the y direction.
So I sum up the flux to
integrate over y direction.
And integrate over y,
so it's 0 to d over dy.
And then every flux, I
still have what I had,
Vx times the h bar
omega and times
f, that's my say kx ky kz.
This is the one where
I started when I write
the flux for all the transport.
Now because this quantity
is the function y,
I integrate the y to get total.
And now you should
be comfortable
converting the summation
into integration.
And so what I have,
0 to d and dy.
And the summation to
integration, what I have is--
I'm using spherical coordinate
theta phi and V. V is constant,
is my frequency.
See I eventually go into
the frequency domain.
So I have 0 to omega max d
omega And 0 to pi, d phi, and 0
to pi d theta.
And the rest is a
Vx h bar omega f.
This f now is f0 plus g.
So g for different directions,
I have different solution there.
I have to split this
0 to pi integration
into two terms, 0
to 90 degrees, so I
can use this g, 90 to 180
degrees, I use the bottom g.
OK, and Vx, what's my Vx?
My Vx-- so now you see
because I took the easy xy
direction, theta y direction.
So I have to project
that V into x direction.
And that V, if I
project the-- remember
it's a spherical
coordinate, right?
Vx is V times sine theta.
That goes to as a mu
plane, xz direction.
And the phi, as mu the angle,
if I align to the x direction,
I have of course phi.
So this one is V sine
theta cosine phi.
So this will be x.
And now when I do solid
angle is theta d theta d
phi sine theta d theta d phi.
When do from Cartesian
to spherical coordinate,
I have sine theta d theta d phi.
And then I have density
of states divide by 4
pi, because of
density of states was
for the integrated
whole solid angle.
So this is the
conversion I have to do.
And at the end, you see I have
to do all those integrations.
And this integration you
cannot do if everything depends
on frequency, relaxation time,
because here s0, I have tau.
I have another Vx.
So actually I will
get a Vx squared.
So here I will have V
squared sine theta squared
cosine phi squared.
Otherwise you'll get 0.
If it's just cosine theta
0 to 2 pi, you get 0.
But I have a square.
OK, and if you do
your integration--
I will skip the detail--
what you have is here is--
I want you to really
sit down and make up
the missing derivations.
But say I'm going to give
you the result. You will see.
And if say the tau and
the V are constant,
or you can say the
tau times the V
equals mean free
path are constant.
OK, so here my condition is
mean free path is a constant.
You go to fluids
problem, when people
do rarified gas dynamics, they
typically take constant tau.
You do heat transfer,
people typically
do constant mean free path.
I don't see a very
good justification
for those choices.
But because of those
different choices,
the final result
looks like different.
And so if I do this, and
of course, eventually you
can write this as your minus
k, but because the integrate,
so is a d dT dx.
And this is the effective
thermal conductivity.
And the end result of
all the integration
is k effective divided
by k, which is the bulk,
because in the solution,
we have here the df0 dt,
this essentially also gives you
the bulk thermal conductivity.
So when I normalize it, I have
k effective k bulk equals 1 8 3
xi 1 minus E3 xi minus E5 xi.
And this xi is the long
dimensional thickness,
thickness divided
by mean free path.
And E is an exponential
function equals
defined as 0 to 1 mu n minus 2
exponential minus xi over mu d
mu.
So this is a function
that in the past
the people actually turbulate.
It's an integral
function of order n.
So this is where I say if you
take a constant relaxation
time, you're not
getting this En,
you actually get a
different exponential.
That's where the difference are.
OK, so if you plot this
effective thermal conductivity
of materials.
This is your xi, which
is d over mean free path.
And this is a normalized
effective over k bulk,
let's say bulk.
And it goes-- so this happens
when this transition goes
to-- this is of the order 1.
You approach the bulk
thermal conductivity
when the material is very thick
compared to mean free path.
But it's small, you
have the deviation
from this mean free path.
So this are the--
in nanostructure, you
say this property--
you eventually should
go back to bulk
when you make it thick enough.
And then if you have a
theory, you sanity check.
When you go back to the
bulk, of say thickness
do you get the bulk properties.
And so this solution
is also called
Fuchs-Sondheimer solution.
Sonderham or Sondheimer--
OK, now I'm putting solution.
And it was developed for
electrical transport.
So the original study was
not on thermal conductivity.
It was measuring the electrical
conductivity of films
that turns out to be smaller.
And the solution is identical
for electrical and thermal
transport.
So you can also say this could
be the electric conductivity
divided by the bulk
electric conductivity,
and the thickness divided by
bulk electron mean free path.
You all have the
same behavior there.
And this is because
the surface scattering.
But here we are assuming--
this is a comment--
we're assuming that
they film deposited
the same as the bulk material.
And very often this is
actually not the case
because when you
deposit the film,
for example, you put a silver
on silicon, what happens
is it's not a single
crystal, it's grains.
So in fact, let's
say the nucleation
when you deposit the material
on top of a substrate,
first you have a nucleation.
So the atoms are nucleate.
They're small dots.
And then there are a
lot of small crystals.
And when you further deposit
it, some of the smaller crystals
disappear.
The larger crystal win.
So your crystal grow
larger and larger.
So the grains actually--
grain size is not a constant.
And in this case,
what you measure
is not just the surface
effects, but the interface
also, because the
grain interface
are scattering centers.
So you just can't
always say it's
this effect that happens at
the surface, interface also.
And the other comment is if
you have a specular surface,
you can, again,
solve the equation.
But the boundary condition
change the boundary condition.
And in this case, what you see
is that the specular surface
do not degrade your transport.
You get what?
The ratio approach 1.
And the reason is, if you
think about this, specular,
even though there is
a direction change,
but there is still the
same amount of-- so this
is the original,
goes here but here.
So in terms of transport in
the x direction, the same.
There's no effect in scatter.
So it's like a waveguide.
You bounce your light
in an optical fiber
as long as your fiber surface
is specular for light,
they go forward.
And there are also solutions
for partially specular,
partially diffuse.
So all those are
existing solutions.
OK, so the original
observation-- those
are the classical size effects.
And the first experiment
was done by Casimir.
First theory was
done by Casimir.
So Casimir turns out to be--
there are many Casimir effects.
And one of those
is heat conduction,
where he explained this
Casimir factor based on--
because there are some
experimental diamond.
I showed before, I commented
before, thermal conductivity
of bulk material is
always looking like this.
At the very low
temperature, it's
proportional to specific heat.
And that's because there
is no internal scattering.
The mean free path is
limited by the boundaries.
So those early experiments,
the size effect was in 1920s.
And Casimir had a theory, I
think it was in the 1920s--
and actually I forget
if it was 1920 or 1910
or 1900, near the range.
But he was explaining
those effects
using the boundary scatter.
So it's also Casimir effect.
One further comment,
in fact those
are the things we're writing
on paper on coherence.
And I was thinking
this weekend where is
this decoherence coming from?
So if I have a film--
we're looking at the
in plane direction.
But the next one I'll
talk about this direction.
So if there is no
scattering inside,
the phonons will propagate
as a wave packet.
But they don't gather--
if there is no scattering,
that wave packet
will propagate as a wave.
So the phase is
actually maintained.
So it's a coherent transport
until it hits the surface.
When it hits the surface,
the Casimir treatment here
is it completely diffused out.
So there, you are
phase is randomized.
And when you randomize
and when you come back,
again, any of those
phonons that are
launched from any direction,
that part is still coherent.
But it's not interfering
with this one
that going up that
direction because the phases
are randomized.
So these are the classical
regime, classical size effect.
Doesn't mean there's no
phase coherence at all.
So I think what I'll do next--
you have heard a
lot now and really
it's a time to take
a look at the other--
the recent literature.
Now you look at it--
oh, no, not this one.
I will say that probably if you
look carefully on these papers,
you should be able to
at least catch something
that we talked in this class
in many, many journals.
I think it's good to look at--
let's take a look at
the nano letters again.
OK so I dare to say that
now you should say look
at the over 50%, some
of these journal,
you should have heard something
and then you should not
be afraid of looking at it.
Graphene-- OK, so maybe
you have quantum transport,
you have ballistic transport.
And solar cell, OK, we are going
to talk about solar cell soon.
As I mentioned, like
some of those protein
that's escaped that.
What do you to think
about this one?
Single molecule direct
activity enhanced Raman
scattering using nanoantenna.
So I would think
that say Raman--
is probably related-- might
be related to surface plasma
where you got the
nanoantenna, there you
have high energy density,
localized density of states
is high, so you will
not be surprised
if you read the density of
states or those terminology
when you look at the paper.
And then when you have
a high local density
of states for
electromagnetic wave,
you can have a
higher Raman effect.
And look more.
I meant, my comment
may not be right.
You can open the paper and
say what it's talking about.
And that's what I do.
I say, OK, anything interesting?
Maybe that's not.
I see enough of a
lot of this stuff.
Bandlike transport in strongly
coupled and doped quantum dot.
What does that mean?
So quantum dot has a
discrete energy levels.
When you put them together,
and the energy levels
start to overlap,
and form a new band.
That's my interpretation
this paper
is going to be talking about.
I didn't look at it.
My guess-- You should go back
to check and see what I said
is correct or not.
Selective gas sensing with
single pristine graphene
transistor--
what's this about?
Anybody can guess.
What happens is that when
gas attached to a surface,
you will change
the charge inside.
And you measure electric
conductivity as you change.
And then when I look at
tighter, OK, the question
is whether you can tell
which gas you're measuring.
You put any dirt on the top,
the conductivity will change.
So the question is, can
you tell which dirt it is?
When people do sensors,
they have to be specific.
I don't know what
this one is doing,
but I would assume it must
be doing some [INAUDIBLE]
or related.
The right image, a single
gold atom with a nanowire.
Maybe nanowire is a
probe of the [INAUDIBLE]..
Again, I'm just guessing, OK.
I want the challenge you, go
back and to develop the habit
and say whether there's
things that you should
be paying more attention to.
This one, they send me.
See this is a work that
Arun Majumdar and Peidong
Yang together, they've been
working on this many years.
And what they observe is
that the thermal conductivity
of some rough in the wires has
a low thermal conductivity that
cannot be explained by
Fuchs-Sondheimer theory.
There are many papers
written on this.
And some people say
because they use this,
they claim they have high
ZT silicon nanowires.
And many people say that's
not probably correct.
So they spend a lot of
time and recently found
that the thermal
conductivity actually
correlate with the periods, they
roughness, different periods.
Here is the-- I
forgot what is this.
But they did a
frequency analysis
in a fractal dimension,
whether that's correct,
whether that's wave effect.
So people are still--
this are very positive.
This is a positive
result. You can see
so that's directly related to
the failure of this one, what
I just said,
OK surface plasma modification
spontaneous emission--
so surface plasma,
again, you heard
it pulsar effect, pulsar factor
is related cavity dynamics.
Phononic bands-- on every paper,
you can make some comments.
That's my point.
OK, we're at chapter 7.
We have three more
chapter to go.
And after that, you
should be able to comment
on 95% of the paper.
OK, go back, spend
some time on it.
And see what my
guess is correct.
And you can make your own guess.